this is a question i'm
nervous to answer i have not begun
another album ariana grande hints at
taking a break from music
[Music]
on thursday the 28 year old singer
answered fans burning questions during a
q a for rem beauty i want to have
a little bit of transparency and honesty
with my fans why not you know and when
asked about her plans to drop ag7 ari
admitted that her focus is on her next
project playing glinda the good witch in
the film adaptation of the broadway
musical wicked after positions was not
ready to start another album yet so i
have not begun
another album that was kind of around
the time that i started hearing
murmurs about a
wicked audition
coming soon so i went into full
preparation mode while i was also
shooting the voice so i was like
shooting and then also doing lessons
every day because i just wanted to be
prepared for when the call came i had no
idea when it was coming but i was just
like i want to be ready
to go in i know that i know the material
like the back of my hand but i still
have so much to learn i want to be prime
conditions nobody was offered this role
off the top everybody had to come and
audition we saw everybody in town who
could who could sing these are tough
songs and everyone had to earn their
position the grammy winner will star
alongside cynthia arrivo who will
portray elphaba the wicked witch of the
west it's off to the races they're
starting people e.t chatted with cynthia
back in february and she dished on
meeting her new co-star ariana is
wonderful that the two of us are
starting to really like find our feet
and find our relationship and really
like enjoy one another's time and space
and conversations she's the sweetest
person the two of us are definitely
excited to sing together i went pretty
hard getting ready and
now thank god the most in thank goodness
literally the most incredible gift of my
entire life is
you know this role that i've adored
since i'm 10 years old
and that is going to have every piece of
me
every minute every ounce of my heart my
time my soul my everything that i can
give it so my hands are quite full with
a lot of
other
thrillifying work at the moment i'm
spending all of my
all of my time
with glinda i just was not ready
the role was first played by kristen
chenoweth on broadway and when etie
caught up with the actress in march she
said she couldn't be happier with the
film's casting i feel great about both
choices obviously cynthia i'm
in complete adoration of i've known
ariana grande since she was 10. so
ariana
i'm very very proud of you she knows i
told her not to not to think about me to
find her own glinda we talk every day i
love you baby girl and it's an honor and
a pleasure to pass the wand in the crown
to you will we see you make a cameo
haven't been asked but you never know i
think i'd be great on the yellow brick
road well a few days after that e.t
chatted with john m chu who is directing
the two-part film and he said he's down
for a cameo from both kristin and adina
menzel who played the original elphaba
on stage the door is always open are you
kidding me but i can't say i'm not going
to say anything i'm not going to do
anything yet but uh of course all of
them that oh that original
cast is amazing yeah so john stayed
pretty tight-lipped but cynthia did
tease this to e.t john chu is excited
very very excited he's working very hard
that i think it's going to be unlike
anything you've ever seen before
that i think we're going to really enjoy
the magic of it and and we're going to
try and put our own spin on on what we
know already and
show you a story about two women that
our system
[Music]
you